Christian McCaffrey the Panthers running
back last time we talked to him he
couldn't even practice yet because I
guess due to the quarter system with his
school he wasn't is that right that he
wasn't able to do this what do you have
here Polly I got Polly just brought me
in the McCaffrey's Rocky Mountain
mustard creamy Dijon wait where did you
get this bully this was in the back
yesterday there's a big box of mustard
wait
Christian what is this McCaffrey's Rocky
Mountain mustard that's a it's a
Colorado legendary mustard my my dad my
dad's face is on it he didn't make it
anything he just put his face on it for
God knows why but it tastes good man not
that does the spicy Brown is probably
the way to go
and this isn't the sponsor of of you
coming on you're coming on behalf of
Dick's Sporting Goods we just got this
yesterday now explain what happened to
the audience last time you were with us
you couldn't even go to training camp
with the Carolina Panthers and the
reason was why yes it's an NFL rule
where um you know I think it you can't
officially practice until your school is
graduated that does not include rookie
minicamp so I could go to rookie
minicamp but I couldn't go to all the
TAS because Stanford's on the quarter
system a lot of West Coast schools are
on it and so even though I was not
enrolled I still couldn't come to even
walk into the facility until June 15th
which was tough but you know that's the
rule you know is what it is I got really
a lot of my teammates are very
understanding you know we'll get back on
the train but it was tough sitting out
that law were you allowed to Skype with
Cam Newton so yeah I could talk to I
could Skype and call and do all that
stuff so I running back coach coach
skipper you know huge props to him he
took a lot of time out of his day to
call we probably talked for about an
hour a day going over all the different
installs I'm just kind of getting them
getting the playbook right but but so
you know we could do that I just
do that face-to-face well what did you
have you gotten hazed yet not yet now
I'm waiting for that does I'm unprepared
you're gonna have to sing probably and
but your music and you're talented so
you should be able to do that I can't
sing I can't sing if they be savory on
piano I might do it was something but I
might I might break a window if I saw as
far as getting together with the cam and
and it feels like at least Mike
shoulders talked about the offense may
resemble what the Patriots are doing it
is that a reflection of what you guys
have talked about or practiced you know
we haven't said that directly but you
know I think you look at all the
explosive offenses around the Legion you
know we want to be a combination of all
one and it's exciting when you hear
about that because you know we we have
so many great tools on offense and we
just kind of got to put the pieces
together and I'll get in sync and
getting a rhythm and make more big plays
and and so I'm excited for the year you
know to help help help those guys you
know and in any way I can last time you
lost a race I somehow lost the race yeah
oh man anything in the combine if you
consider the comment I didn't run the
fastest time so that was a race to me
and I lost but but head to head last
time you don't say head to head to head
right him man I'm in probably my high
school track days out last time I ran a
head-to-head race so that'll probably be
last time were you a two-sport athlete
or more than that yeah I played three
sports I played three sports in high
school and then four sports all
throughout little leaks I played
football basketball track and then and
literally got played baseball to second
best sport was what oh that's tough I
thinking when I was growing up and I'm
like little little league baseball is
probably my best sport but then you know
I stopped playing baseball and
basketball kind of took over so I'd go
football basketball and basketball
tracker probably tied actually but it
feels like that - sport athlete is gone
the
Oh Jackson Deion Sanders that it's
really hard it feels like that these
kids get locked into one sport growing
up and there's travel teams makes it
tougher for them to be playing other
sports you see that then now you didn't
experience that but it feels like guys
get in on one growing up no definitely I
say I mean I think that's the biggest
sin - I'm not a fan of you know locking
into one sport I just think it's so
important as a kid to to venture off and
do multiple things and it's so tough
nowadays - because you know a lot of
these you know baseball teams are all
year round and the only way you're going
to get playing times that you're they're
all your ass can't play tennis was and
to me I think I look at you know what
basketball and track and baseball did
for my football career and was more than
more than anything you're training
different muscles you're training your
you know your mind and just being a part
of multiple teams you learn a lot of
life lessons - so for me I am I look at
the lessons I learned in basketball you
know quickness agility leaping ability
hand-eye coordination all that stuff I
use in football all the time you know in
track obviously linear speed and so just
being able to you know do multiple
things is extremely important and I
think just it's worth it as a kid to go
through that first time you dunked was
when ah the start of eighth grade was
the first time I done what I'll never
forget is that a that montbello rec
center and one of my best friend growing
up Marcus Wilson he was always the same
same size saying you know same
everything as me and you know he went up
and someone threw a little lob to him
and he one hand dunked it and from like
dang if he did that I have to do that
and then we went and did it on the same
day but how tall were you back then
oh no I'm tall I was at that time I mean
you're on 11 now alright yeah I'm
sitting on a good day okay okay so your
sixth round I'm a big I'm a big round up
guy of course I don't blame you when
you're 511 you always have to round up
to say the worst height to be
would you rather be 510 than 511 yeah
I'd rather just say I'm 5 and look good
now when I sorta like yeah okay you're
fine
when's the last time you got caught from
behind oh man I don't know do they have
an angle oh yeah it's always always tell
okay if I'm just if I'm just running you
know straight and I didn't have to make
any moves so no one could come from
behind I don't think I've been caught
from behind but you know there are a lot
of times I'll be running have to make a
bunch of different moves so I'm going
laterally but if I'm just you know foot
race I can tell you the last time I got
customized your pro diet compared to
your college diet how different oh I
think it's you know it's very different
just because what's available to me you
know before it couldn't pay for a chef
or anything or a nutritionist and all
that stuff so it's tough to just have
the resources and get everything you
want but now you know I have all the
resources and I can really specify my
diet to all my deeds you know pretty
much perfectly what did you do with your
first paycheck oh my I put it in the
bank I'm doing anything with it you
haven't done anything extravagant no I
mean I'm trying to trying to save that I
got my my Nike account so I got all my
clothes from my Nike account other than
that man I just I train and I spend
money on food I guess but other than
that I just kind of keep it low-key
what are you rolling in now when you
drive oh I got a BMW now but but uh I
didn't pay for it people at Sonic Auto
help me out there so you're a pro you're
allowed to get all these benefits now I
know you're joining us on behalf of
Dick's Sporting Goods and also you have
a youth sports weekend you wanted to
talk about so I'll give you the
opportunity to microphones yours now I
appreciate it yes so Dick's Sporting
Goods is doing a pretty cool thing part
of their sports matter program this
weekend where 1% of in-store online
mobile whatever any
kind of their sales are all going to
youth sports teams in need across the
country and so any anyone who comes in
with with anyone 18 or younger and if
they're wearing his or her youth team
uniform or team gear whatever it may be
their Jersey whatever they'll get 20%
off their purchase at hold it starts
Friday and in Sunday I just I mean it
hit me hard because I was shocked to
hear that their you know their school
sports budgets continuing to be cut and
you know there's there's actually kiddo
that it can't afford to play even at the
little league level and to me and I
think you know that that needs to be
addressed so I think it's a great thing
that Dix is doing you know you look at
the life lessons you learn you sports no
I can I can definitely attest to that
and you know to give kids an opportunity
to do that as importantly so I jumped
right on board can you beat Cam Newton
in a race of 40 yeah that sounded pretty
confident there yeah I couldn't beat him
in a throwing contest I can get it what
about a bench press I don't know if cam
benches I don't know if you're supposed
to plan to the shoulder so right now
yeah hey congrats glad you got into camp
good luck with the Dick's Sporting Goods
and the sports weekend it starts today
thank you a good talk to you Gunn
Prescott yeah I appreciate it thanks for
having me on
that's like Christian McCaffrey Carolina
Panthers the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience